it's sort of funny and scary that Donald
Trump is so unprepared to be President
of the United States and discussions of
impeachment have already started and and
most progressives seem to understand
that the president needs to do something
worthy of impeachment you can't just
impeach a president because you don't
like them at the federal level article 2
of the United States Constitution says
in section 4 that the president
vice-president and all civil officers of
the United States shall be removed from
office on impeachment for and conviction
of treason bribery or other high crimes
and misdemeanors
you can't just impeach the president for
being a fool otherwise george w bush
would definitely have been impeached but
not that long ago in June of 2014 Donald
Trump tweeted about wanting to impeach
President Obama for being quote
incompetent the tweet that Donald Trump
sent out on June 4th 2014 says are you
allowed to impeach a president for gross
incompetence so the answer is no it's
fascinating that the guy who is the most
incompetent elected president in the
history of the United States wondered
two years ago whether you could just get
rid of Obama for that same reason
however Trump's actual potentially
impeachable offenses have already
started to such a degree that both Obama
and George W Bush Ethics lawyers have
said that if Donald Trump doesn't
resolve his conflicts of interest with
his businesses before his inauguration
on January 20th he would be in violation
of the Constitution on day one of his
presidency and as many of my friends
pointed out we were talking about this
over the weekend on the one hand Trump
is one of the most likely to be
impeached presidents up in in a long
time based on his systemic conflicts of
interest but he's also one of the
presidents who would be replaced by
terrible person after terrible person if
you look at the potential Trump
succession list you have of course the
president is the president followed by
Vice President Mike Pence followed by
Speaker of the House Paul Ryan followed
by President Pro temp of the Senate who
we believe will likely be
orrin Hatch followed by the Secretary of
State which could be MIT Romney which I
guess of this list of deplorable would
be the least bad but it could be Rudy
Giuliani or David Petraeus or John
Bolton or others followed by secretary
of the Treasury Steven you can uh you
can is that is minuchin up followed by
Secretary of Defense James Madison
general Jeff session so in on the one
hand yeah I understand why people are
talking about impeachment of Trump
because the guy unless he makes a change
to his arrangement with his businesses
would be in violation of the
Constitution on day one but at the same
time you've got a basket of deplorable
--zz lined up to replace him and ye how
many people would have to go away before
we got somebody reasonable I don't know
it makes me wonder if Donald Trump chose
Mike Pence as a sort of safe guard okay
now that was an impeachment effort it
wouldn't come from the Democrats it
would come from the Republicans that's
what was joked about when McCain chose
Sarah Palin as his running mate in 2008
assassination attempt against John
McCain would be uh so low because nobody
would want Sarah Palin to be President
of the United States and up from earlier
in the show we were talking about uh dr.
ben Carson being named a secretary of
HUD Housing and Urban Development the
silver lining is ben Carson would be
12th in line so I guess he's pretty far
away uh I I don't know it's it's really
I sort of agree with you because now
that we're talking about what a disaster
Trump would be I still am very much
aware that pence is far more dangerous
than Trump in many ways and when we
think about all these scenarios of Trump
not of but being given the 270 electoral
votes on December 19th or Trump being
sworn in but being impeached Mike Pence
is the guy waiting in the wings which is
an absolute danger to the United States
yeah I totally agree I mean Donald Trump
is a demagogue and there's a million bad
things you can say about him yeah but
he's at least shown willingness to work
with Democrats and I think that's why
he's gonna end up staying it I think
it's not worth progressives investing
too much time talking about a trump
impeachment because the replacement or
replacements are are actually worse in
many ways of progressives will be much
better served thinking about how to make
actual change working on issues working
on elec
that's exactly what we're going to be
doing with the progressive engagement
coordinator position that will be
created through the upcoming
crowdfunding campaign which we'll be
announcing of later this week